the eight precepts of death are the main
antagonists of season four of my hero
academia now if you want to know more
about their leader then check out my
overhaul explained in two minutes video
this video that you're currently
watching will focus on the other members
of the group and will be running through
their quirks all in about five minutes
or less with no plot spoilers but before
we begin I'm nearly at a hundred subs so
I would really appreciate it a lot if
you would subscribe
the general manager of the eight
precepts of death is a guy called mimic
now he does have a fantastic work and
for any one of you who's played the game
prey then the concept of his quirk will
be quite familiar to you he can
basically transfer his own body and mind
into solid inanimate objects and then
manipulate those objects as if those
were his actual body now under normal
circumstances his base quirk is usable
and objects that are no bigger than the
average sized fridge but pay attention
to this next part because it might get a
bit confusing we've established that
when he's inside objects he can
essentially move them around as if they
were his own body but in that form he is
unable to perceive his surroundings so
imagine you transferred your
consciousness into a football you
literally have no perception of reality
and so to get around this mimic
manifests the relevant body part on the
exterior of the object where necessary
so it's a good quirk but if you don't
have the relevant body parts manifested
at the right time it leaves you wide
open to being attacked or taken by
surprise now moving on to overhauls
direct assistant that's a guy called
chrono stasis when I first saw chrono
stasis on mast I genuinely thought it
was a girl but putting that aside
chrono stasis his quirk allows him to
slow down the movements of anyone he
hits with his weird extendable hair
however he can't actually extend his
hair unless he is standing perfectly
still now if you can see from this image
he has both a minute hand and an hour
hand on his hair and the duration of
time for which his enemies are slowed
down basically like moving in slow
motion that depends on which hand he
hits them with okay so now I'm moving on
from the more senior characters to the
lower members of the 8 precepts of death
specifically a group known as the 8th
Expendables which if you're part of this
group is a pretty offensive name firstly
let's take a look at kendo rapper and
hijiki Tang guy these two have pretty
complementary quirks so I thought I'd do
them together
now rapper is the type of guy who never
misses a gym session he is absolutely
massive
and his quirk which is known as
strongarm allows him to rotate his
shoulder sockets at extreme speeds this
basically allows him to dish out a
constant stream of unrelenting punches
however after a while he does actually
need to stop which leaves an opening for
enemies to attack him but this brings us
to the reason why 10 guys quirk is calm
mentoree because while rapper is all
about attack 10 guy is all about defense
his barrier quark allows him to create
these telekinetic barriers which are
comparable to the strength of a steel
wall so while it's not indestructible
it's incredibly hard to break here
unless you have like all my levels of
strength and unlike rapper 10 guy
actually keeps his emotions in check and
has a pretty calm disposition I think he
was kind of designed to be a parody of a
monk just by the way he like moves his
hands around and talks but moving on
from these two characters we have shin
Nemoto he views himself as pretty
special among the 8 Expendables as he is
the only one who over who actually
entrusted with his plans
so his quirk is called confession and it
forces anyone he asks a question to to
answer truthfully this is extremely
useful to have in any organization as
you can ascertain people's true
intentions very easily however whilst is
quiet guarantees that people will tell
him their truth it doesn't guarantee
that people will tell him the truth if
that makes sense people can tell him
what they perceive to be true but if
it's not true then you've got false
information now because his quirk has no
offensive capabilities he normally stays
strapped now the next character up on
the list is dead Doros ceccacci okay
that's actually the first time I said
that out loud and he has a pretty
undesirable quirk called sloshed
and when I say undesirable I don't mean
that this quirk is necessarily bad it's
just not very exciting like it's not
something that I would want to have
so basically sloshed causes any person
who approaches him to lose their sense
of balance very similar to the feeling
of being drunk he can essentially act as
a type of stealth villain because if he
hides his presence people will basically
begin to feel the effects of his quirk
without even knowing why which would
confuse the average person if they
hadn't been drinking his character
design and his personality appears to
reflect that of an alcoholic which is
pretty appropriate now moving on from
sakauchi we have three Expendables who
are pretty closely linked so I'm gonna
do them all together and that is Hojo
setsuna and Taub a Hojo's quark is
crystallization and it grants and the
ability to produce these really hard
crystals all over his body this is
effective for both close-range attacks
and defense now we know that at some
point in his life he had a job of
producing gems
and when the Jemez turned out to be
worthless he was discarded and found on
the streets by overhaul in fact setsuna
was another person found by overhaul on
the streets and has a pretty awesome
quote called larceny his quirk would
actually be really really good for a
hero larceny allows him to instantly
move objects from the possession of
someone else directly into his own hands
similar to teleportation he primarily
uses this power to disarm his opponents
turning them into easier targets for
Hojo and Taub a to deal with there's
also a size limit on what he can steal
from one person with large enough
objects being impossible to take away
and he's also unable to use his quirk on
objects that he can't actually see so if
something's out of his line of sight
then he won't be able to use his quirk
on it meaning that he is completely
defenseless if for some reason he is
blinded or can't see now moving on to
table base quark
this is another undesirable quirk that I
definitely would not want but it allows
him to basically chew and eat anything
that he comes into contact with on top
of that his stomach is sturdy enough to
digest pretty much anything he's eaten
however if he does eat toxic substances
he will eventually get sick but finally
the last member of the eight precepts of
death is katsu karma his quirk is called
vitality stealing and it gives him the
ability to absorb the stamina of others
just by touching them now this quirk is
actually really good because it has the
advantage of not just strengthening the
user but also weakening your enemies at
the exact same time and he can use other
people's energy to increase his own size
which is possibly the reason why he's
incredibly swole under normal
circumstances he needs to make contact
but if his quirk is awakened then he can
do it from a distance without even
without even touching the people who is
stealing vitality from and with cuts to
karma done that is the entirety of the
eight precepts of death with the
exception of overhaul now if you want to
see my two-minute explanation video on
overall the link should be on the screen
right now but before you do that please
subscribe to the channel I'm trying to
get a hundred subscribers by the end of
October I would really appreciate every
single sub I appreciate it guys peace